(Risas)
Lo sé por experiencia.
El programa era "Salvado por la Campana: La Nueva Clase" de NBC.
Y caractericé a Weasel Wyzell,
un tipo de carácter lento y nerd en el programa,
fue un reto actoral muy importante
para mí como niño de 13 años.
(Risas)
¿Creyeron que era el número cuatro, mi ceguera?
¿Por qué?
Hacemos suposiciones sobre las llamadas discapacidades.
Como ciego, me enfrento a suposiciones incorrectas de los demás
sobre mis habilidades todos los días.
Sin embargo, el tema hoy no es sobre mi ceguera.
Se trata de mi visión.
Quedar ciego me enseñó a vivir mi vida con los ojos bien abiertos.
Me enseñó a observar los peces nadando hacia atrás
que nuestras mentes crean.
Al quedar ciego lo puse en perspectiva.
¿Qué se siente ver?
Es inmediato y pasivo.
Abres los ojos y está el mundo.
Ver es creer. La vista es verdad.
¿Cierto?
Bueno, eso es lo que pensaba.
Luego, desde los 12 a los 25 años, mis retinas se deterioraron progresivamente.
Mi vista era cada vez más extraña
como una sala de la casa de la risa de espejos e ilusiones.
El vendedor al que le hablaba en la tienda
era realmente un maniquí.
Al inclinarme para lavar mis manos,
de repente veía que era un urinario, no un lavabo,
cuando mis dedos sentían su verdadera forma.
Un amigo describió la fotografía en mi mano,
y solo entonces pude ver la imagen representada.
Los objetos aparecían, se transformaban y desaparecían en mi realidad.
Era difícil y agotador ver.
Uní imágenes fragmentadas, transitorias,
analizaba conscientemente las pistas
buscando algo de lógica en mi caleidoscopio en ruinas,
hasta que no vi nada en absoluto.
Aprendí que lo que vemos
no es una verdad universal.
No es una realidad objetiva.
Lo que vemos es una realidad única, personal, virtual
construida con maestría por nuestro cerebro.
Me explico con un poco de neurociencia de aficionados.
La corteza visual ocupa aproximadamente el 30% del cerebro.
Eso es en comparación con aproximadamente el 8% del tacto
y 2 o 3% de la audición.
Cada segundo, los ojos envían a la corteza visual
nada menos que dos mil millones de piezas de información.
El resto del cuerpo puede enviar además solo un adicional de mil millones.
Así que la vista es, en volumen, una tercera parte del cerebro
y puede consumir cerca de dos tercios del procesamiento del cerebro.
No es de extrañar entonces
que la ilusión de la vista sea tan convincente.
Pero no se equivoquen: la vista es una ilusión.
Aquí es donde se pone interesante.
Para crear la experiencia de la vista,
el cerebro usa su comprensión conceptual del mundo,
otros conocimientos, recuerdos, opiniones, emociones, la atención mental.
Todas esto y mucho más está vinculado al cerebro más que a la vista.
Estos enlaces funcionan en ambos sentidos y por lo general son inconscientes.
Así por ejemplo,
lo que se ve impacta en cómo se siente,
y la forma de sentir, literalmente, puede cambiar lo que se ve.
Numerosos estudios demuestran esto.
Si se les pidiera estimar
la velocidad de un hombre en un vídeo, por ejemplo,
su respuesta será diferente si se les dice que piensen en guepardos o tortugas.
Una colina parece más pronunciada si acaban de hacer ejercicio,
y una meta parece más lejana
si llevan una mochila pesada.
Hemos llegado a una contradicción fundamental.
Lo que se ve es una construcción mental compleja,
pero experimentada pasivamente
como una representación directa del mundo al alrededor.
Creas tu propia realidad y lo crees.
Yo creía en la mía hasta que se fragmentó.
El deterioro de mis ojos hizo añicos la ilusión.
La vista es solo una manera
de dar forma a nuestra realidad.
Creamos nuestras propias realidades de muchas otras maneras.
Tomemos el miedo solo como un ejemplo.
Tus temores distorsionan tu realidad.
Bajo la lógica retorcida del miedo, nada es mejor que lo incierto.
El miedo llena el vacío a toda costa,
haciendo pasar lo que le da miedo por lo que saben,
ofreciendo lo peor donde hay ambigüedad,
sustituyendo los supuestos por la razón.
Los psicólogos tienen un buen término para ello: horrificación.
Exacto.
El miedo sustituye lo desconocido con lo horrible.
El miedo es la autorealización.
Cuando se enfrentan a la necesidad más grande
de mirar fuera de sí mismos y pensar críticamente,
el miedo se bate en retirada hacia el interior de la mente,
encogiendo y distorsionado la opinión,
ahogando la capacidad para el pensamiento crítico
con un torrente de emociones perturbadoras.
Al enfrentan a una oportunidad atractiva de tomar medidas,
el miedo te arrulla a la inacción,
tentándote para observar pasivamente cómo sus profecías se cumplen a sí mismas.
Al diagnosticarme mi enfermedad causante de ceguera,
sabía que la ceguera arruinaría mi vida.
La ceguera era una sentencia de muerte para mi independencia.
Era el final de los logro para mí.
La ceguera significaba que iba a vivir una vida ordinaria,
pequeña y triste,
y probablemente solo.
Lo sabía.
Esta era una ficción nacida de mis temores, que yo creía.
Era una mentira, pero era mi realidad,
al igual que los peces nadando hacia atrás de Dorothy.
Si no me hubiera enfrentado a la realidad de mi miedo,
no habría vivido.
Estoy seguro de ello.
Entonces, ¿cómo se vive la vida con los ojos abiertos?
Es una disciplina que se aprende.
Puede enseñarse. Se puede practicar.
Lo voy a resumir muy brevemente.
Házte responsable
de cada momento, cada pensamiento,
cada detalle.
Ve más allá de tus miedos.
Reconoce tus suposiciones.
Aprovecha tu fuerza interna.
Silencia tu crítica interna.
Corrige tus ideas erróneas sobre la suerte y el éxito.
Acepta tus puntos fuertes y débiles, y entiende la diferencia.
Abre tu corazón
a sus bendiciones abundantes.
Tus miedos, tus críticas,
tus héroes, tus villanos,
son tus excusas,
racionalizaciones, atajos,
justificaciones, tu rendición.
Son ficciones que percibimos como realidad.
Opta por ver a través de ellos.
Optar por dejarlos ir.
Eres el creador de tu realidad.
Un gran poder viene con una gran responsabilidad.
Elegí salir de túnel de miedo a un terreno desconocido e indefinido.
Elegí construir allí una vida bendecida.
Sin estar solo,
Comparto mi vida hermosa con Dorothy,
mi hermosa esposa,
con nuestros trillizos, a los que llamamos Tripskys,
y con la última adición a la familia,
la dulce bebé Clementina.
¿A qué le temes?
¿Qué mentiras te dices?
¿Cómo puedes embellecer tu verdad y escribir tus propias ficciones?
¿Qué estás creando en realidad para ti mismo?
En tu carrera y tu vida personal, en tus relaciones,
y en tu corazón y alma,
tus peces que nadan hacía atrás hacen mucho daño.
Tienen un costo de oportunidades perdidas y potencial no realizado
que generan inseguridad y desconfianza
cuando buscas satisfacción y conexión.
Los insto a buscarlos.
Helen Keller dijo que lo único peor que ser ciego
es tener la vista, pero sin visión.
Para mí, quedarme ciego fue una bendición profunda,
por la ceguera logré la visión.
Espero que puedan ver lo que veo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Isaac, antes de irte, solo una pregunta.
Esta es una audiencia de empresarios, emprendedores, innovadores.
Tú eres director de una empresa en Florida,
y muchos probablemente se están preguntando,
¿Cómo es ser un director ciego?
¿Qué tipo de desafíos específicos enfrentas y cómo los superas?
Isaac Lidsky: Bueno, el mayor desafío se convirtió en una bendición.
No entiendo la retroalimentación visual de la gente.
(Risas)
BG: ¿Qué es ese ruido? IL: Sí.
Así, por ejemplo, en los encuentros del equipo de liderazgo,
No veo las expresiones faciales o gestos.
He aprendido a pedir mucha más retroalimentación verbal.
básicamente los obligo a decirme lo que piensan.
Y eso se ha vuelto, como he dicho,
una verdadera bendición para mí y mi empresa,
porque nos comunicamos a un nivel mucho más profundo,
evitamos ambigüedades,
y lo más importante, mi equipo sabe que lo que piensan realmente importa.
BG: Isaac, gracias por venir a TED. IL: Gracias, Bruno.
(Aplausos)